well um I never intended to be a
historian of religion I my aim was to
become a professor of English literature
in a university but I had a series of
absolute career disasters and found
myself making television programs about
the nature of religion or about
Christian history and started to
discover about other religious
traditions and that was an absolute
eye-opener for me because in fact the
study of other traditions doesn't
necessarily make you want to convert to
another tradition but it helps you to
see your own differently and expands
your outlook so I learn to lock from
both initially Jewish and Muslim
theologians that had been missing
perhaps from my rather parochial
Catholic upbringing from the rabbi's of
the early Talmudic age I learned that
there's never a last word on god there's
you always continue to question even God
Himself can be questioned and you can
keep arguing with one another and there
will be no end to this conversation
about the divine because and no human
expression of God can be ultimate from
the Muslims I learned from the
extraordinary pluralism of the Koran the
fact that the Koran endorses every
single one of the major world faiths and
I was particularly enthralled by the
Sufi tradition the mystical tradition of
Islam which it's quite which is so open
to other religious faiths it's quite
common for a Sufi mystic to cry in
ecstasy that he's neither a Jew a
Christian or a Muslim he's at home
equally in a synagogue or mosque a
temple or a church because when one's
glimpsed the divine ones left these
man-made
stink shins behind there's one quotation
I discovered very early in my research
is very early and it just opened huge
doors to me it's by the major Sufi
philosopher and mystic eben arabi lived
in the 12th and 13th century and is
still deeply studied by Muslims today
and it goes like this do not praise your
own faith exclusively so that you
disbelieve all the rest if you do this
you will miss much good nay you'll miss
the whole truth of the matter god the
omnipotent and omniscient cannot be
confined by anyone greed for he says in
the Quran wheresoever you turn there is
the face of Allah everybody praises what
he knows his God is his own creature and
in praising it he praises himself which
he would not do if he were just but his
dislike is based on ignorance and I
suppose from the time i read that one of
my objectives was to knock down those
barriers of ignorance that hold us back
from that kind of open-hearted
depreciation of the unanimity of the
human quest we fought for the divine